nucléaire avec le sort de la centrale de
fessenheim est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quand cette centrale qui est la
plus vieille de france va fermer elle
fermera au moment où le père de
flamanville sera mis en fonction puisque
dans la loi il existe un plafond à
plafond gigawatts d'électricité issue du
nucléaire ce plafond il ne peut pas être
dépassée il est à 63 2 gigawatts alors
je vous trois électrons différemment s
conséquent le gibier rivière mange il va
te faisais nucléaire parfois on fait
quelques raccourcis et c'est pas évident
de comprendre ça veut dire que pourquoi
on connecte fessenheim à flamanville
parce que une fois de plus ses 1300
mégawatts la puissance 1600 mégawatts
par des mois la puissance du dieu le
père de flamanville une fois que
flamanville est raccordé au réseau
franchi ce plafond est donc bien
évidemment quand ça entraîne la mise à
l'arrêt de nos dix manches de fessenheim
aujourd'hui le calendrier tel qu'il est
indiqué par edf et l'asn que je rappelle
que le fait de mettre en route une
centrale nucléaire
et c'est d'ailleurs assez rassurants
lundi pour celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui décide mais c'est l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui est une autorité
indépendante c'est elle qui donnera le
feu vert et legault aujourd'hui et des
retards importants sur cette paire elle
avait échappé à personne
je crois que ça n'a échappé à donc l'été
2010 neuf non c'était avec a reculé
cependant je crois on est plutôt sur la
fin de l'année 2019 dans le calendrier
tel qu'il est il est indiqué par edf et
par l'autorité de sûreté n'a jamais y
aura jamais de fermeture de fessenheim
est à 11 milliards d'euros j'espère que
le père des marins jours donc je je je
je pense qu'il démarre à tout de même
froid non plus qu'on se fasse peur
inutilement on qu'on raconte n'importe
quoi
moi je les ai déjà dit me suis rendu
nombreuses reprises à fessenheim j'y
retournerais au début du mois d'octobre
la fermeture de la centrale est
irréversible a d'ailleurs le projet de
territoire que nous avons lancé lui
aussi acte bien c'est irréversibilité il
y aura des compensations d'ailleurs pour
professionnels oui l'idée c'est d'être
exemplaire c'est ce que le président de
la république m'a demandé sur ce sur ce
dossier alors il ya plusieurs moyens
d'être exemplaire en dessinant un projet
économique pour l'après centrale pas
tout seul d'ailleurs parce que c'est
aussi la responsabilité des
collectivités territoriales je mets un
peu les pieds dans le plat mais je me
suis un peu agacé récemment parce que
sallèles centrale de fessenheim ses deux
réacteurs nucléaires en plein milieu de
champs il ya rien autour donc ça fait
des dizaines d'années que personne n'a
réfléchi au développement de ce
territoire autour de la centrale
donc maintenant falloir que non
seulement on gère l'après centrale mais
qu'en plus on arrive à faire
développement économique
ap a été fait par 140 ces quarante
dernières années bon c'est ça être
exemplaire être exemplaire c'est la
question fiscale dans le projet de loi
de finances
tel que nous le présentons est tel que
gérald darmanin ya travaillé on met en
place pour la première fois des systèmes
de transition de fiscalité pour les
collectivités territoriales pour amortir
le choc
en clair permettent pendant 3 à 10 ans
trois de manière presque et dix ans de
manière dégradé de continuer à percevoir
une fiscalité alors que la centrale sera
plus en fonction et ça aussi c'est sur
les lieux les territoires est-ce que
sébastien cornu si finalement le père de
flamanville voit le jour et fonctionne
fonctionne un jour est ce qu'il faudra
faire d'autres réacteurs repères on sait
qu'il ya un rapport remis fin août qui
évoquait l'hypothèse de six nouveaux
réacteurs opère à partir de 2025 en
construction à partir du 25
alors on n'en est pas là d'ailleurs le
rapport disait oui ou non il y en a mais
juste pour préciser pourquoi le rapport
10 avec une focus pour nos éditeurs il
faut comprendre le rapport dit si on
veut maintenir une filière nucléaire à
terme à long terme dans ce pays a
abandonné faut construire des centrales
sinon on perdra le savoir faire c'est ça
la thèse et qui est sous entendu dans ce
dans ce rapport c'est là où on n'est pas
là nous ne n'est pas là parce que déjà
on la première la première priorité
c'est de diminuer la part du nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique
aujourd'hui c'est le tour de 75% il faut
le ramener à 50% dans les délais les
plus brefs donc ça c'est la priorité
absolue ce sera la priorité de la fin du
mois d'octobre dans le cadre de la ppe
est ensuite pardon mais il faudra quand
même faire une pause images sur sur
flamanville sur le père de flamanville
pour interroger deux modèles industriels
et modèles économiques avant de prendre
des décisions supplément un mot sur le
plan vélo sébastien lecornu ça régresse